[Music]
Sam Allen welcome to Stanford University
and the system's leadership course thank
you so much for coming yeah it's a great
pleasure to be here right now as the CEO
of John Deere tell us a little bit about
the company and where it is today you
know a history of a company that's a
founded in 1837 but also where it's
headed to over the next decade
so as you indicated we're 181 years old
we're a company that started in Ag and
specifically in Ag implements we're
celebrating actually this year the
hundredth year of acquiring the Waterloo
gasoline engine company and getting into
tractors which today we're known much
more for tractors but over the last
number of years we've also diversified a
lot so if you look at our businesses
we're clearly number one in large AG
equipment globally we are also number
three globally now and construction
equipment we're number one
globally in forestry equipment or a
large provider of turf equipment both
here in the US and in Europe and then
we've got about a 40 billion dollar
captive credit company as a part of that
so the company is much more diverse and
I think that showed up in the last few
years in that we just finished 14 15 and
16 three years in a row of revenue
reduction 34% from the peak to the
trough that's only the second time in
the last 50 years that's happened the
first time we lost a lot of money
other the end of the third year and
quite frankly the company almost went
under in the mid-80s this time we had
came right out of it with our tenth best
year ever and we're strong enough that
we could buy this five put five billion
dollars to buying this construction
equipment company a road building
company called virgin so a company today
is much much stronger it's growing and
it's growing on a lot of different
fronts not just in traditional AG even
though by far our largest business is
still a large AG and when we think of
John Deere we think of big green
machines and yet the world is changing
as these devices become increasingly
connected and digital's playing a much
stronger role in your business you've
been doing autonomous systems for many
men
years and you recently acquired blue
river where I founded by a grant a
Stanford graduate tell us a bit about
how digital's changing your business
yeah it has in in all parts you know if
I take a more holistic view certainly
the Internet of Things is having an
impact on us on how we're thinking about
working with our supply bases our
manufacturing facilities how we're
communicating with each other
we have since about 2010 been putting
telematics solutions on our equipment so
our equipments been we have more pieces
of equipment out in the marketplace with
a telematics solution than anyone else
which was the foundation for a lot of
this for us and then over the last few
years specifically since 2012 we've
really really have created a vision for
us on where we want to go with precision
AG which digital is the foundation for
all of that and it really has taken us
from the standpoint of looking at
agriculture and Agra quipment and
farmers managing by a farm field and
managing for insights by capturing data
through the course of the year looking
at it during the winter time period and
then replanting in the in the spring
time we're really on a journey now with
digital were literally from managing
farm fields were in sight of seeing us
managing plant by plant which is what
blue ridge River will help us do and
getting real-time information off the
field and creating insights and
intelligence from that that causes us to
do things different with the equipment
right there at that moment as opposed to
having to wait to the following year now
you've been with the business a long
time is the CEO of the company how do
you think about blending the type of
domain expertise that you've had in
Deere for so many years with new
competencies and capabilities people who
come with digital backgrounds and the
digital natives you know it has been
something in some ways we've had to deal
with this for a number of number of
years in other ways digital especially
artificial intelligence piece has
brought up
a different opportunity here you know if
you think for example we've had an
engineering Center in India if now for
almost 20 years so you've managed that
culturally differently than you do an
engineering center that we have let's
say in Moline Illinois and we have
another one in Kaiserslautern Germany
and again there's some cultural pieces
there that that you end up picking up
when we were first going down the path
and I think the best example I can give
as an embedded software engineers
embedded software engineers versus
regular software it's very very
different and you you do things quite a
bit differently regular software with
agile development you you know you you
you iterate quickly if you're getting an
embedded software computer that's on
that tractor it's one of seven computers
on there the day you launch it it better
be 100% right so you have to create
literally inside of our system you had
to create a software group that has got
to be very process oriented to do it
right the first time and a little slower
then you have another group that's got
to be very very fast to market with
solutions and then iterate fix them
quickly and now we've added this
additional pieces as we go down the
artificial intelligence piece is the
center of that is out here and so it's
not you just know you're not going to
get the brainpower to come immediately
to Des Moines Iowa for example you have
to come here so we have had some
experience of this because 20 years ago
when we first did our first GPS systems
we did those out of Torrance California
and we still have that down there in the
LA area because that's where all the
government contractors are and we've let
that group run it's been connected but
it's been loosely connected at the start
and very slowly became more and more
integrated with endear and that's given
us really the roadmap if you will what
we have to do here we knew when we
acquired Blue River that you know it's
it's got to stay almost like a startup
and the culture of
but you'd have the security of a fortune
500 company and so the key is to
understand that and then we've developed
you know a couple areas where we say now
guess what you're part of a fortune 500
public company you have to do this one
of those is governance compliance and
the other is our accounting processes
but other knapp we we really want to
create if you will a definitely a
different culture here let it be
maintained and over time just continue
to instill dear values into that culture
it will always be different but it will
still have more and more bleeding green
as time goes on
now as the leader of the business you I
heard you say that you want to enable
those organizations to take all the
attributes that made them great
independently but slowly bring them in
how do you think about when's the right
time to be infusing green into them and
how do you know that what's that that
magical sauce a magical time that allows
you to do that well certainly on the
digital side somebody like Blue River
it's going to be a different answer than
this company we acquired vert c'n there
are three and a half billion dollars
themselves they have five brands that
one will be much more defined by at
which time we have integrated more dear
technology into the products and we can
see at a point in time and it may never
be but at a point in time when we say
okay it's time to change the brand and
dear brand now add something to it when
you're out here you don't have those and
the the what you're gonna in my belief
what you're gonna trust heavily on this
person that's leading the organization
out here you're going to continue in
this case gate you're going to
continue to expose him to all the
management activities so all are well in
September we'll have our every other
year top 300 meeting he will be an
integral part in that meeting he's we
have a leadership session every spring
he's he's been in those
he's been meeting with our management
team he presents to the senior officers
he will get the exposure he will start
seeing okay here based on what we have
as a culture here's something I think
that dear does that we would really be
interested in picking up but you're
going to rely heavily that the boots on
the ground
pulls it you don't want to force-feed it
all right so let's transition talking
from internal issues to external issues
as you blend increasingly physical and
digital and the products and services
how do you see your business model
changing over the next decade well
number one we know it is going to change
that's part of it
number two one thing that we don't think
and we don't think we're naive about it
that isn't going to change is and most
of our businesses we go through
independent dealers into the customer
and because the type of work activity
they're doing you know planting for
example this time of year when they're
planting they have a two-week window
they're working 12 14 hours a day the
machines got to be up all the time you
you you've got to have a dealer right
there that can turn it around get it
back up diagnose it and turn it up so
dealers are still going to be a part of
it
they're the the role of the technician
will be different instead of chasing oil
leaks
they'll be also much more on the Digital
side much more looking at okay that
telematic controller what do I need to
do here might be a part of a software
update they may have to do that type of
thing we also have are going more and
more away from selling a piece of
equipment a tractor a planter combine to
saying that we want to provide a total
solution let say a corn solution and the
solution will be connected all the
pieces will be connected which will
allow us to do more optimization of the
equipment but will also allow us to
aggregate data from there that will
provide the customer insights why am I
getting 220 bushel an acre on this field
and over here I'm getting 180 or the 15
other people that have their
data aggregated in her system the
average of those is 280 and what can I
do differently to to end up improving my
yield and/or reduce my cost of inputs
and those bundling of services will
become more of a service component that
we sell not just the initial equipment
itself and how quickly that gets
monetized that's something that we
wrestle with and challenge with and the
best example I can give you of that we
have for over 18 years had an auto steer
system which you can show the customer
that they have a payback on that system
in nine months the adoption curve from
zero to getting to almost all of
equipment in North America coming with
that optional auto steer system took
about 1718 years farmers are just very
very conservative tradition bound so as
we try to think about how do we monetize
some of these solutions one of the
things that that we will wrestle with
compared to some is that we have a
customer base that is is somewhat
reluctant to move that direction and
you've got to go with the the
leading-edge individuals get them to
adopt it and then help hopefully spiral
it out to others but we do believe
certainly that we're going to change
from selling just iron to selling
solutions and selling information that
provides insights all right so as you
get that information in solutions and
you really focus on customer outcomes
increased productivity lower costs how
do you work with your channel and we see
this with the auto industry where
they're trying to figure out how do they
work with their existing partners and
yet you're trying to get data from the
end-user so that you can deliver
products how do you manage that dynamic
actually I think this is one where I
think we've gotten on top of it pre
pretty well if if you would go back to
just 2015 we bring our dealers together
annually for about two and a half days
we told them in in 2015
you're either going to get on this
precision egg bus with us or you're off
the bus and we put together a robust
program with here's how you get to
precision egg 1.0 here's how you get to
precision egg 2.0 and here's the
timeline you-you-you have to get there
first you have to know how to to service
telematics solutions etc later on you
have to know how to do machine
diagnostics then you ought to get to the
point you have an agronomist and and
that the dealers have rapidly
transformed - today we've gone from less
than three four years ago I would argue
less than 10% of our dealers we're
really prepared to support that where
now we're at 80 percent working on the
last twenty percent we hope that we'll
get there by the end of this year so
they're there now and the good news is
once they get there they really see the
value of it today's session today with
the students is going to be managing at
intersections I don't know if we have
any other company that comes in that's
doing this as acutely as John Deere you
know farming which has been with us for
thousands of years now going from a very
physical world to a physical and digital
world and we're very appreciative if
you're taking the time to come to
Stanford and speak with us Sam thank you
for coming - Stan's a lot thank you so
much
you